[Laughter]
i want to talk about
the reason why i don't call myself a
womanist no more
fem woman switch it up switch it up you
know what it is
can't say the word unfortunately because
of youtube why can't you be a womanist
and hold people accountable why why do
you feel like the label
or the title necessarily contradicts
that idea that's what that's cool well
what happened is that i
became into confrontation with other
people that don't consummate
consider me as such because i hold them
accountable
okay so you felt like other womanists
would would not call you a womanist
because you were held well yeah also oh
wouldn't because i was holding them
accountable
every time you go against the movement
or you just question some things or some
values or some views of a movement
why are you denying me my humanity and
it's not why are you
arguing against my right to exist i'm
not gonna argue with you
because i deserve to be able to breathe
the same air as you
that has nothing to do with what i was
saying you know what i mean i had
nothing to do with what i was saying or
anything it's just that
i feel like that thing that you're doing
right there or what you're pushing there
is not right and there's some flaws
and some holes in that you know what i
mean what you're trying to push
there's some holes and it's not exact
and you're not really looking
at every angle of this thing trans
people are people
that's not what i said but i'm saying
trans people are people yes absolutely
yes women are equal
yes that's not the point that's not what
i said but you understand that women
are adults who can make their own
choices see this
it doesn't forward the discussion it
doesn't it doesn't help the discussion
yeah i understand that now can we move
on to what we're saying
like i'm not gonna argue with you about
my right
but it's not about to breathe air i'm
not gonna argue with you
about my right to
walk that's not why i'm not gonna argue
with you
about arguing with you i'm not
gonna argue with you
because i exist yes and i deserve to
exist you're not going to argue with me
about my humanity
definitely we're not having a discussion
there is no discussion
i exist therefore i am therefore i'm
correct
but that's not what i'm saying correct
yourself the way i'm correcting you
corrections you're acting like a
correctional officer
is that what's going on no redemption so
i can't even like we can't even discuss
this it's like the absolute
truth absolution oh is that what you're
looking for no that you don't deserve it
wow why okay cause you're
man oh wow that's brilliant by the way
but yeah but but you know what comes
before man
throw yourself in the garbage throw it
throw you
that was versa
we are woman because we are more man
we are more than man for we are woman
it's just want to know how we're winning
because we got a w in
man whoa man
that's whoa man
i woo man oh man with my lyrics
oh wow again no no it's all good it's
all good but it's
i dab dab okay
y'all already know what time it is the
way i damn damn
the fools that go against feminism
they are not worthy of humanism
remove their life life life
you know our problems are life rife rife
with
masculinity that really sounds like a
knife knife
knife trying to cut throat trying to cut
throat and
instability of all of this this
this misfits you don't fit in this
what you think you're doing is wrong
dawn don't hear the bell
i didn't see
that was the worst movie but anyways
sorry you know you feel like
you don't get called and i was not
helping i was not even helping my cause
i was like forgetting everything that i
was
going through everything everybody goes
through different things and then i
realized i was
the more i was helping people i was like
every time i was bringing up like
something that happened to me
this is what i was messed with uh when
when when you got promised i'm like
that's exactly what the hell you don't
like when they do to you
yeah if you bring up like male 1 or
you're different yeah and i was like
yeah but there
are problems it's like everybody got
issues we would be even
stronger if we would solve these issues
together like i have
i scratched my i scratch your back you
scratch mine but unfortunately that's
not what it is
everybody is for themselves do you feel
so
do you feel like it's similar how you
can be like down
for the sentiment of black lives matter
but not necessarily be
a black person it's like similar yes
it's similar it is similar
there's like a division and then the
disconnect into like the black lives
matter movement sometimes
like i understand why it's it's there
for and why we need that
but then there's other extremes and i'm
like whoa whoa
whoa and if you question even as a black
person even if you're white
if you're white shut the [ __ ] up you bet
not just open your mouth
on black issues because you're not
allowed to talk you're not invited at
this table
you're not at the cookout you're not
taking care of the potato salad
booboo honey chicken cherry child uh but
as a black person
you're going to be quickly casted into
an uncle tom and it's not even i was
like
yo can we think about can we use our
brains
instead of our emotions let's just just
talk about facts
you're saying we should kill all white
i'm not saying it that's what they said
but i've heard people go about that it's
a
minority but even them you can't even
refute that
when people go into extremes you can't
even
question that you become an enemy no no
and then i just gave up i was like you
know what do your thing
do your thing with your issues do your
thing i'm just going to live my life i'm
not even going to go like and it go it
goes like that with being pro-black a
lot of people like
on my case for being pro like i was like
okay you know what deal with you
i'ma do i know what i do i know what i
bring to the table i know what i do for
my community
and so at some point claiming that
you're a womanist it's like first thing
it's like you're promoting for no reason
you're boasting for
you don't need to say it bill gates
don't have to say that he's a
millionaire
but you got all these people that are
not millionaire that are just hood rich
flashing money
and be like yeah i got these i got these
bands man
i got d no if you were really rich rich
you wouldn't have to flash like that
if you would really same thing with a
woman is if you really are
that you don't have to flash it you
don't have to if i'm i don't
have to say i'm pro-black i am
i'm just i live where i live you know
what i mean other people are going to
cash in and everything
just boasting that it's just uh now i
understand that if you're like doing a
a um protest and stuff like that you
show your
that's okay but on everyday life i'm
gonna do me i'm gonna be but when i
call i call bs when i see bs
but it's hard to communicate with people
in that realm you cannot maneuver yeah
no i get what you're saying
your margin to maneuver is really
smaller i can't go like this
i can't go like that i can't question
anything because you're gonna be crushed
and then i'm like you know what i'm not
interested you know what
okay [ __ ] it and when i when i finally
said [ __ ] it i had a bigger monster you
could call me the all the names that you
you want to call me i know what i'm
about oh well that's good because you're
like this like who are you don't even
know me you don't know
so i don't care about you i don't care
about what you think and i think that's
how you
go forward in life questioning yourself
i remember when my mom used to say
hey
you think it's uh you think it's a smart
thing to do that and now i'm just
questioning myself
man is it a smart thing to do that why
is she question why is there
why is there a question there why is
there
no hmm there's a question i should
reflect on that but
no it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't work
on that so that's a bit wider
the reason why you have less margin of
maneuver you can't talk
anybody if you're not part of the group
at least you'll be able to talk and
you're going to be on the same level
no if you're with us you shut up and you
follow us hold my pocket
[Music]
that's how i feel now you pretty much
nailed it i can't add much
i got nothing to have johnson you did
great
it's just as i was thinking about that
and it's like yo you can't talk
even on the other side man's activist so
now that you're no longer with us do we
leave like
women should go back to the kitchen or
like what do you want when you want
their places i mean i like a sandwich
once a while
but my girl she makes me sandwich
because she wants to make me a sandwich
she's not like a thing whatever woman
should be in the kitchen
man should be in the kitchen there's
food in there be a grown up and learn
how to
cook you know i mean it's just it's just
that to me that's just
hey babe when we eat it but just ketchup
and then you don't even know what the
power you are kitchen just going around
the house doing so
like that's just that's not the woman
stuff that's just stuff yeah
i'm not gonna
argue with you because i exist
yes and i deserve to exist you're not
going to argue with me about my humanity
we need to balance a balance that's it
balance
you know that's what that's what i see
that's pretty much it
[Music]
me